Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the
congressional request that may be behind
the president's unexpected announcement
Nancy good morning good morning the
president's decision appears to have
stemmed from an amendment that went down
here on Capitol Hill earlier this month
leadership sources tell CBS News that
during a debate on military spending
House Republicans asked the White House
for guidance and support on an amendment
put forth by Missouri Republican Vicky
Hartzler hart slurs amendment proposed
blocking the use of taxpayer money for
transgender surgery for service members
now republicans keep in mind were not
asking for a total ban on transgender
people in the military which is why the
president's announcement came totally
out of the blue and in fact hart slurs
amendment came up for a vote two weeks
ago and failed a couple of dozen
Republicans joining all Democrats to say
that transgender troops should be
covered for gender reassignment the
chair of the Senate Armed Services
Committee John McCain slammed the
president's decision saying that there
is no reason for anyone who is well
trained in the military to be kicked out
regardless of their gender assignment
thank Thank You Nancy a lot of people
feel that way thanks a lot